on day three of our pet week here on
good day las vegas and today
we're going to ask who let the dogs out
all about the dogs this morning
bianca holman live at the hydrant club
downtown with what you need to know
if you're training your pup your new
friendly furry friend in your house
bianca let's get straight here on some
details
yeah so no we're in the dog days of
summer right so we're all about the dogs
today we're at the hydrant club and
we've talked about
choosing the right dog for your family
and lifestyle two
getting your dog's attention and
establishing firm
but yet loving authoritative figure over
the dog and so now i'm joined by kathy
brooks with the hydrant club so now
walking the dog right why is this so
important
walking the dog is the most important
tool you have for establishing your
relationship
strengthening your relationship and
building that relationship with your dog
you're literally taking your dog into
the world
showing them that you are the steward of
their experience in the world
so oftentimes we see dogs out there you
know pulling at their
owner or the owners pulling at the dog
it starts with the leash show us kind of
the
the proper way to walk your dog so um
when i'm doing training exercises with
my dog i'm usually holding the leash in
my right hand with the dog on my left
because i'm
you know using my body with the leash if
i'm just kind of strolling down the
street got a cup of coffee in my other
hand
i'm holding the leash usually on the
side where the dog is when you'll notice
when i move forward bridge your heel
that was very good by the way
she's really smart she's learning so
when i move forward with my left leg
moves you'll notice that bridger
moves with it and when i stop he comes
to a stop bridger sit
that should have been an automatic sit
again he looks like we've got a little
work to do today
but the idea is he's immediately next to
me you'll notice that the leash has a
nice loose
j shape he's not way out in front he's
not all the way behind he's not fly
fishing
out in front of me you'll also notice
where my attention has been granted you
have a microphone in my face and i'm
talking to you so my attention is up and
around
i'm not looking down at the dog when i'm
carrying a bag by a handle i don't keep
looking at the bag to make sure it's
still in my hand
if the collar is on the dog and i've got
the leash firmly affixed to the
to the collar the dog's attached to it
and i noticed you said we said yes we
can train
our dogs all day but it's also the human
that has most of the the power so
some things you were saying put your
headphones away what are some other tips
that you see
owners doing that you know deters from
walking your dog properly
the number of people i see walking down
the street or i see the top of their
head
because they're looking down at their
phone and the dogs out
doing whatever they've got their headset
on you know so they've got the volume up
so they can't hear
things that are are coming nearby when
i'm with my dog i'm paying attention to
the environment
around me what's coming from any
direction what's behind me
i'm glancing down in my dog i'm looking
at my dog to make sure that my dog's
doing okay
but if i'm you know doing something else
i don't see the hamburger on the
sidewalk that my dog's gonna get its
mouth on
right bridger all great tips and you see
all four of these are hers let's get a
look at them these are the brooks
children
exactly so we've got some more great
tips and kind of things that you can
start thinking about when it comes to
your four-legged furry friend
or how many legs we got here four times
four six sixteen
sixteen that wasn't my strong suit come
on now all right
we're gonna send it back to you guys in
the studio
kathy and you guys can stick with uh dog
training that's kind of locked in we'll
worry about the math later on
good tips certainly for dog owners out
there guys we'll catch up with you later
on this morning as well